Toronto Canada we're coming up North
this week gang and we added a third show
there at the Royal Theater still a
couple of ticks left grab the squad come
out and see us yeah gang also uh at rug
garbage.com we have a 20% off all of our
merchandise you go over there toies
slashing prices no promo code need you
just go over there boom it gets whacked
off right when you go to the checkout
get all your official ay merch and then
also over there on patreon we're doing a
contest or if you sign up and if you're
an active patreon user in October of
2023 you get your chance to be on our
garbage interviewed by the big man and
myself do it sign up it's a party
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage it's that
little show we sit down to your favorite
comedians and we find that if they gr up
to be classy yeah or if they're just a
big old piece of trash garbage I'm your
host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in the new edition she's upstairs
getting the Halloween candy ready we're
talking fulls siiz Snickers we're
talking fulls size razor
blades my co-host is coming at you from
across the table it's a family episode
circle the wagons yeah just the boys the
bozos and the homies he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is international businessman
and my best pal in the whole wide world
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan Toby
where's my camera hey what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
over there on iTunes which we're
climbing up the charts that used to be
you thought that was dead in the water
YouTube was where it was iTunes were
Skyrocket throw a review on there drop a
review over there we haven't said that
in a long time really do I mean we say
it but shake them up a little bit you
don't mean it yeah let the [__] know
the boys are back in town get the Ops
going got the Ops going crazy is that
what we're doing that's what we're doing
um and then obviously full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are true the roof cooking baby
cooking then I I'd be remissed if I
didn't mentioned the amount of stuff we
got going over there it's a lot on Ru on
patreon.com garbage your greatest go arm
website in the world uhuh uh which we've
never announced we never talked about
publicly what's that the contest oh the
big cont test if you are the the the
chatter people if you are an active
patreon user in the month of October of
the Year 2023 you will be entered to win
a spot as a guest on are you garbage who
oh baby that's what I'm talking about
talking with the [__] homies figuring
it out uh if you sign up over there uh
before the end of the month you will
automatically be in the running for it
we're going to pick 10 finalists they're
going to submit videos going be a whole
thing all Deets are on there check it
the Freak Out gang bribes accepted I
mean people have been sliding in the DMS
with with with one guy offer me his
sister I was like hey pal I'm a married
man but send them pcks let me see what
she looks
like gang how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses the te's and dots the
eyes give it up for T-Bone mccuins Toby
McMullan everybody hey what's up boys
what up T-Bone you guys are looking
great today you know that thanks you're
looking so good just want to apologize
again for being late yeah here you go I
knew you were buttering me up you not so
much oh I am disheveled I had a good old
school wake up look at the time freak
out dude you came in like a dog who just
heard fireworks you were [__] you
were on the couch under the bed you came
in frazzled you get a cone on your head
I'll give you this though you didn't
push the shower which I respect you
didn't shower oh not at all cuz she
still had the the the the puff in the
back we were all saying you were going
to come running in uh through the front
door toies uh with with your wet hairir
cuz wet hair Toby usually has it tooe
yeah wet haired Toby D sorry s I'm
smoking a Sig I remember remember the
one time he hit us with that we were
like Columbus or something he came down
late and he's I'm smoking a Sig we're
like oh man you were in your head up in
the room you were you were doing you
were fighting your own battles buddy
have too take it the wet hair man I
don't know why it goes back to when I
was a kid and there'd be there'd be
people girl on the on the bus with wet
hair and all you smelled was their
conditioner turning you down left and
right ew
gross getting shut down by a wet rat
you're asking them what they're having
for lunch what' you what'd you get today
that smell of of wet hair in the morning
it just killed me well my hair doesn't
dry for like nine hours it's a whole
thing MH I get it I I look disgusting
get a hair you're all right kid we
appreciate it man don't sweat it at all
uhhuh um and one last uh one last call
to the [__] Army of garbage up there
in Toronto uh this is if you're hearing
this I think this is dropp in on uh on
Wednesday and Saturday we got the eve
before the eve before the weekend we're
in [__] uh Toronto added a third
[__] show at the Royal Theater we're
either currently jammed up in a Canadian
prison yeah we'll see what happens or
we're just getting into the hotel
looking forward to it I put my passport
in my bag yesterday nice I was like I'm
going to forget it I have this now yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I I got to find I got
to get eyes on mine really I keep it in
a handful of places case I hide mine too
I usually keep it in a in in a pocket of
a suit that doesn't fit anymore they
ain't going to look there they're going
to look at that suit like there's no way
there fat pigs been getting this on well
that is uh this is this is a pretty good
top we never talked about the Trashy
hiding places the suit jacket all time
but everybody knows that if I'm breaking
into your crib I'm going for that inside
pocket oh yeah oh that what do you mean
no one knows that's everybody's hiding
spot no that's what I tell myself cut
this I got some pearls
hidden bunch of original issu Starburst
and stuff in
there this is the third not my mango
cherries this is the third Jolly Rancher
ever printed w we used to have a hook up
with Jolly Rancher I would tell you
about that my fraternity brother uh his
dad was a chemist was a Jolly Rancher
Rancher and his dad would show up with
bricks like keys of like flavors they
were [__] like like Walter White like
a giant sheet of blue dude was awesome
this is Pure
Glass I don't know if I ever told you
what I have is a hiding device
butthole hey what are you doing it's my
safety deposit box got all my good docs
in there uh got your war bonds I have
which I'm I'm I I'll I'll say it now cuz
I'm changing in it you shouldn't reveal
where you keep your your goods sure I
got a fake I bought a fake Bible with
the key and I I have it in a stack of
books you can't tell I don't trust that
cleaning lady is that a bunch of
hustlers sticks out like a sore thumb a
fake Bible yeah at first glance it it
does the test but if you start snooping
around it's plastic what do you got in
there what Emergency rogain Couple of
couple of hems case she get jammed up
couple of
hers uh couple of blue CHS in case the
mood strikes uh I did have a I did keep
my watch in there until I lost it your
watch I had a I bought a nice watch and
I was in Germany last year the one that
I seen the with the with the the tan
thing with the tan band no that came
from our great friend's movement oh okay
uhhuh what watch did you have I had it
for about a week and I lost it now
what's a nice watch boss okay yeah all
right what' you get 2005 2006 when' you
pick this up no last year Hugo Boss try
Hamilton my friend man every American
president has had a Hamilton watch that
he just learned that the other I'm
telling everybody dud you talk about
[__] classy guy Ronnie Chang told me
that that's just pure insecurity you go
just watch a boo company ah president no
Mr Chang confirmed it oh great watch
great watch company every American
presid but you didn't know that going in
there I knew nothing I thought Nick the
Greek ripped me off is this a
schmon came with two tickets to Book of
Mormons uh do you remember back in the
day I saw my neighbor had for the first
time it was uh they got real big the the
cans they were for weed dealers and
stuff yeah I know what you're talking
where the bottom of the soda can or the
top of the soda can screws off and it
feels like a full can they put like
Concrete in there or something man I
remember seeing that for the first time
blew my mind and then with my friends uh
in high school started moving weight
they would have like the Pringles ones
and stuff like that like you would open
up the top and it would still be sealed
but in the bottom there was like a QP
you know what I mean any chips in there
couple officer sourer creaming
onion uh I'll be honest with you I got
nothing I got nothing hidden just my
passport that's the only thing really uh
value that I would have yeah I I I kind
of like social security cards and [__]
like that just in a in a in a file
drawer um which I do have a new social
security card I had to get replaced that
and my birth certificate got lost Off
the Grid yeah they all got lost you're
losing a poker game something I don't
know what happened to it but it was all
[__] up I also don't have that CH you
don't have your social security card no
or my birth certificate did we do a
background check on you when you started
working here good luck there's no
paperwork I'm sure it's down we just
have a handshake deal I'm sure it's down
at your mom's I'm sure they have all
that [__] they sent it up I promptly
lost it oh really oh yeah you can get
that stuff sold it for a new skateboard
or something you get that stuff um I I
feel pretty good of like when I leave my
apartment I go there's nothing if
someone were to break in there's nothing
of real value I don't have only the cat
everything else just yeah only the cat
the cat my and my I me belonging the one
plant that I have I would be upset if
they nicked that upset yeah I'm saying
of value I mean I have a computer like a
$900
old [__] MacBook but that's about it
anything else is I there's like maybe a
hundred bucks in cash and like ones if
you had to get out you got a minute to
get out yeah what are you grabbing the
Bible because there's about three grand
in
there my passport kid real
religious it's all so broken like the
covers it's just real bad I got to get I
got to get something new I think I'm
just throwing safety deposit box at the
local bank really keep everything in air
that's real adult my handguns gold I
would just want to do that to to be able
to to do the experience to walk in there
you both got to turn the key then you
tell the broad to beat it or whatever
the whoever's open up empty bag yeah you
always have to grease the guy or that
only you don't Grease the guy that only
when you got when you got blow in there
yeah that's when you need them to look
the other way yeah yeah get yourself a
couple of new suits that's what you get
out of here yeah but you're allowed to
keep cash in there as long as it's
claimed cash I believe what's that mean
who knows that's the whole point see
bank they they know what's up that's
what a real goods are nobody ever goes
to the safety deposit box I don't think
they can get in them no no shot I think
it's very hard unless I mean didn't they
do that in uh Inside Man Doug McCree can
get in there come on Doug Doug crack is
safe shout out to the town um yeah that
that was yeah I I don't know I don't
know what people with stuff I don't have
anything valuable yeah me neither
TD Banks got my cash what would you grab
so you grab the Bible the Bible's got
some cash in it okay
um if I like who's is there someone
after me it's all going down everybody's
got to get out you got to get out and
you got to get moving apocalypse not
apocalypse you're going to need a little
money the heat is on the heat something
yeah all right I'm asking do I need a
weapon sure I'm grabbing my knife from
the spoke post spoke post sent me about
10 of them and my martini
shaker smoking a cocktail I'll be right
with you just sit anywhere no it'll mess
with me with my extra long spoon my
swizzler um yeah I'm cashing a knife the
dog and the bird the keys of the car and
your passport that's it passport no I
mean if what if you want to travel I
guess if I'm if I'm getting away from
federal law yeah grabbing a passport
going down to Guatemala or something
okay I'm grabbing the cat
uh a skateboard without question got a
shred gotta go get a session I gotta
stay mobile boys uh cat skateboard uh
probably my now that you're saying it I
would grab my passport now but I
wouldn't have thought to
beforehand maybe like a one photo I
would like to keep and then uh yeah I
don't really own things yeah I'll just I
really don't either my winning
attitude grab a comb on your way out the
door for the
apocalypse dude you're not going to
believe it train was so slow dude yeah
I'm grabbing the cat also that's Toby's
excuse on this train I mean it was very
slow today today it don't dude when
you're jammed up it always is slow they
know well when you leave the house an
hour late everything's slower whoa whoa
minutes uh I I want to talk about this
big faux paa me and the big man the
other night went down to the uh along
with stuff Island went down to the old
Phils game shout out to the fighting
Phils them fighting Phils down there at
Citizens Bank Park and uh you know we
were drinking you weren't really
drinking I drank myself stupid um but he
this I took some shroomies yes this was
a very F which I found in my in grab a
nose assorted drugs yeah I didn't get to
say I would grab my my cat I'd grab my
PL I'd grab my dad and my Nexium and my
passport M I don't have any cash can't
be jammed up at immigration with [__]
acid reflux they're going to know you're
you're up to something I mean if
something was going down I wouldn't make
it a couple of days I'd be miserable be
real Moody I got to have my NE seat I
got to I got to um but yeah something
that's never happened to me in a 27-year
drug career was I had two little micro
does that I didn't the one I knew about
cuz it was cracked and I put it in a bag
and I just left it there didn't [__]
with it but then in the bottom of the
cookie jar there was one sitting there
and I was like man I'm slipping that
seems like a dangerous place to keep
loose drugs a cookie jar we don't keep
cookies in there oh all right yeah they
not mix them with the Oreos I don't who
knows what you're doing over there those
are in the safety deposit
box turn your key Mint
Condition yeah just some some giant man
turned his back as you pull out an
original twinking just like yeah yeah
never did that before never like you
know oh I didn't even realize I had it
there was never I was always cry I found
this in the bag of my thing never in my
life I know where that [__] is at all
times GPS but found it anyway yeah I
wasn't drinking too much um but big this
is a very faux PA of Henry he he thinks
he's acutely aware of all the
surroundings at all times
Toby move but there's I don't like that
I don't like that already and you know
he just operates with huge blind spots
sometimes you know what I mean and we're
there there's an older couple in front
of us uh and down the line it goes uh it
goes big man okani me Tommy uh from the
aisle out we got the aisle big man you
know he's he's got some we need some
space got the aisle right behind bom
Third Base a little bit back in the left
field perfect [__] shot never seen
that angle before got to see Alec bow do
a couple of [__] rippers over the
first base I got to tell you man those
guys are athletes you mean the
professional athlet how far that [__] is
and they just [__] wing it and the
ball curves right into Harper's hands
let's go
um but we were the beer run somebody was
going to the bathroom it was a little
disjointed of acquiring alcoholic
beverages we weren't on the same page in
a good way cuz like I would go and like
you could only get two beers so you you
were coming back and we had a and then
we were buying them we had a surplus of
beers at our feet a like I don't know
four mhm right and they were big boys
four glugg like four fuckingn ofers four
24 oers yeah I'm talking ipas Miller
lights Bud Lights I was running the
gamut sweet couple in front of us she
was turning around giving a high five
she was loving it B and I had
noticed excuse me I had noticed in the
beginning of the game that they
had sorry that they had their bags
tucked under their seat like they had
their belongings under there they had
gone to like the official merch store
they had like all this so all that
shit's about to go to Splash Mountain
which Isen it was like the goddamn log
FL it's a dumb move it's a dumb
move dude I'm throwing down peanut
shells like I'm in a bar in Deadwood
just [__] hitting the floor that's
what you're supposed to do his right
foot comes in like a snowplow and just
it's like he's bowling down there it was
maybe the fifth sixth inning all the
glugg all over these people's belonging
170 o didn't didn't even think of their
didn't even think of their stuff and I
just remember seeing all the beer
running down the aisle and I'm like you
know what are you going to do it was an
accident and I didn't really notice them
after 120 oz of of assorted beers dude
that's of surf sides in there that's
340s imagine that it's like a college
brochure tons of diversity oh man um and
I'm tripping pretty hard at this point
too over the
beers in my defense those beers wouldn't
stay still
yeah I was zooming a little bit dude and
they I didn't notice any of this and I
feel I felt and feel terrible about it I
was thinking about it this morning in
the shower just it was such a wonderful
environment everybody's high-fiving
we're [__] we're all there that
[__] baseball park is came through
and fied it and didn't even think about
they're going to be telling that story
remember we were we were at the game
felt so bad I felt more bad for the for
for the husband because when the first
home run got hit it was like real back
and forth for the first three Innings
and then uh caso's [__] hit a [__]
cracker and she was [__] doing
something and I remember him like
looking like looking back like where the
[__] is she you know what I mean I I've
been in that situation like she's
[__] missing it you know what I mean
I felt bad for him real cool cucumber
you are didn't even think about it dude
so she I clock it obviously I'm aware of
my surroundings I immedi well I just see
the you got a pigeon on your head I see
the waterfall ofpp right it's like it's
like to the point where it's going down
multiple STS was bad and they're like
dude she's she picks up a b a blue you
know those like napsack bags like the
drawring napsack she picks it up and
it's like it looks like someone turned a
sink on it's just dripping onto the
ground and she's like she's doing this
looking back hoping to get anybody and I
don't want the eye contact cuz I'm you
know so I'm like I'm darting my eyes
away but I'm still like stuck in the
story see I want to see how this pans
out dude he then picks up his bag it's
worse somehow it's just it's just
dripping beer all D he pulls out he's
got like a t-shirt a hat all all just
[__] beer stain I didn't see any of
and he's like slap hands like he's got
no clue dude a goddamn ball game going
on here high five high five he's out to
lunch this [__] and I didn't know
they stopped turning around and
high-fiving and stuff like that but I
just didn't think about it man cuz see
what happened they were so upset dude
the eyes she was starting was insane she
didn't look at me did she yeah huh she
do did like like imagine like the the
huh uh like look she just wanted up my
bad why did they say something I would
have said I'm sorry I would have took
them to the store bought them anything
they [__] wanted split of pizza with
them which I never got never got my Mac
and Max Kip what do you know about
Factor what do I know about Factor what
do you know about Factor I've been a
client of factor you ever had the turkey
chili is that are you trying to offend
me on Dorney adre you ever had their
cauliflower mash dude I'm shredded
chicken taco bowl if they could send me
12 of them a week daddy gang we love
Factor over here at Ru garbage and you
should love it too cuz it's America's
number one ready to eat meal kit you
throw it in the microwave two minutes
eat right up the thing or you want to
get fancy like give me n you throw it in
a skillet and you put it on a plate like
a gentleman yeah that's the way to go
and also a little tip for you I talked
to t-bone about this if you're watching
your carbs you get one of those those
those low carb or no carb Tor you throw
it in air you got have a little bit of a
burrito and then you got you got some on
the side it's like appetizer and an
entree all while staying low cow or keto
whatever you want to do you can choose
from over 35 weekly meal options with
fall flavors like cranberry peacon
chicken apple Dijon pork chops uh so
many options there's every there's
something everyone in the family will
fall in love with like I said they got
vegan vegetarian keto calorie smart I'm
a calorie smart man Protein Plus meal
options no matter what your goals are
factor can help you get there it takes
the guessing out boom you got something
at the crib cuz I know for me I'm a
fatty if I have if I to make a decision
I'm making the wrong decision I know I
got factors at the crib I'll go home
whip something up to minutes head to
factor meals.com garbage and use code
garbage 50 to get 50% off that's codeg
garbage 50@ Factor meals.com garbage to
get 50% off do it let's talk about Mt
mobile shout out to mintmobile I don't
know if you know mint mobile but do you
like you like wasting money on uh on big
big company phone plans I'm not a fan of
it you like throwing $100 $200 down let
me let me ask you this do you like like
$15 a month plans starting at $15 a
month do you like that Ryan Reynolds who
don't he's a good looking kid and a
smart businessman he was the owner sold
it kids doing all right and they're
passing those savings right on the you
cuz they got no brick and mortar it's
all done online get over there and sign
for mmobile today yeah all their plans
come with unlimited talk text highspeed
Data uh 5G brought to you on the
nation's largest 5G Network look at that
boom put that in your pip bite down all
right uh as I said for years uh my
wife's been a a customer of it it was
easy peasy you know a bird she was
coming here we needed to get her a phone
I I I just Googled this is five six
years ago I just Googled uh cheap phone
plans for this for my bird here and it's
popped up we've been using it ever since
it's fan freaking tastic I use your own
phone keep the same number all the
contacts everything the only thing that
changes is the bills and the cash that
stays in your freaking pocket uh to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com garbage back to
that show back to the show man I felt
terrible about that I really did what
happened was is I was in tune with the
vibrations of the universe they were
they were real we hey relax the beers
were real wonky and then he goes to
sneaky heater and I say shout out to
wait want to hear all time [__]
I'm going to sneak a heater I go big man
I'm going I we're hitting home runs left
and right I'm wasted I'm like I got to
catch a heater I'm in Citizens Bank ball
park I'm catching a heater I [__] go
out I go you want to go he goes no I'm
good I go out to catch a heater who do I
bump into who's also going to catch a
heater Tom Jones Pat oh [__] no idea
either either one of us are at the game
we locked out what the [__] are you I'm
I'm going to cat heater he goes let's go
right this way by [__] cranking
heaters on the [__] on the mezzanine
so he's gone for a little while I'm out
of I'm out of the I think the second or
the first or second IPA that I drank and
you know reserves are running low you
got to keep the juices going uh so the
Surf Side guy comes rolling around so me
and okani get like four surf sides the
The Ice teas hanging Ted so I start
drinking that I'm like you know what
these are much going down much smoother
than the [__] ipas cuz they're not
filling up my stomach and stuff like
that so I'm like all right I'm switching
over and then he comes back like 10
minutes later with this big gulp sized
it looked like a garbage pale kid it was
like [__] like the graphics on it it
was just it was it was like Devil's
juice or something it was Heavy it was
thick I spilled some on my hand still
got the Mark Mark of the Beast had D
vinegar on it to get it off and I was
just like well I'm not [__] drinking
this so I just put that right there on
the edge and left it there and then a
few minutes later I looked down and it
was it was it might have been that girl
that W that that walked in and out I
don't remember actually kicking it yeah
you on [__] goofballs pluton yeah
it's [__] up man I felt I feel bad I
didn't want to ruin their time it you
didn't make their night I tell you that
much man very upset well I didn't even I
notic I remember them leaving right away
yeah or they left at like the eighth
inning or something and that was because
of me they yeah they left before the end
of the game I don't know if that's
because of you and by the way you ran
out of there at the end of the game we
didn't even get to do the [__] uh the
the colum Scott song with everybody I
had to do it up there I went to pee I
would have stayed for another could have
stayed why why I was said I'm running to
the bathroom I thought we were all
leaving I you then you were wrong I said
I'm running to the bathroom before that
line gets crazy oh I didn't hear you uh
in your in your defense mhm playoff
baseball hey you're in come on you're
not on drugs and you're not hammered
what are we doing it's also like it's
not even that that happens dude you put
your [__] under the seat at a baseball
game what the [__] are you thinking I've
never left a [__] baseball game where
it wasn't complete disgusting no you're
not you're not wrong that's the Boneyard
dude yeah that's for boxes that had soft
pretzels that's for soda cups nacho
cheese yeah dude yeah you're not I mean
you're not wrong it happens I don't I
think they were just dude volume of
liquid and the the pure not zero
acknowledgement of the pain they were
feeling at the time I didn't see any I
didn't see them ringing out the clothes
I know why you how how about you give me
a heads up hey you see what you did no
I'm not getting in your mess that was a
mess I would have [__] got them hot
dogs or something like that all right
well hey all right hey guys I'm sorry
about the beer you see this dragon in
Centerfield is Jesus
pitching man oh God if by any chance
they're not listeners if they are
they're not anymore they got they got
off the patreon for maybe a nephew or
something of theirs is if there if
anybody in the Philadelphia area's Aunt
Uncle mom or dad or somebody you work
with you know how many is complaining
about some fat pig that was standing
behind him at the baseball game that
ruined their time hit me up it was me
you know how many people are going to
just say it was their a or uncle just
for free I remember what they look like
I'll need pictures
yeah okay
uhhuh anyway Phils won sure that was a
good game great game I got something for
you fellas um hold on I did want to have
it was a pretty fun moment we're waiting
in line to get in we we uh having beers
beforehand right we hopping in Uber and
Philly does the thing that New York
doesn't really do you can just grab a
sixer they'll just give you a sixpack to
go shout out to ferges in Philly so we
grab a sixer of Pounders we hop in the
Uber we're like cool if we have some
Pops in here he goes I don't care we're
popping in the Uber we get down we hop
HP in line I'm cranking heaters cuz I
know I'm going to have them inside but
they're limited I can't have them my
free will you know what I mean so I'm
cranking heaters in line and this kid
goes [__] Gippy Foley are you garbage
and I never felt like I was carrying the
brand more than chugging chugging a
[__] warm Miller Light and cranking a
heater as the guy as I'm walking through
security just like I'm sorry walking
through dud walking through a metal
detector blowing out smoke and shout out
to Chris o'conor for the move of the
night probably in a blackout State
negotiate negotiates an illegal Uber
pickup in the middle of Broad Street the
middle of an intersection the guy he
goes I'm like he's like let me see if
this guy's available like a black SUV
pulls up he's like are you picking
someone up and he's like yeah he goes
how much to not and he's like 40 bucks
we're like get it we just [__] it
took about it took about 10 minutes and
two lights for us to all get in the car
he was pulling away as I was getting in
everybody was it was a we were people
were booing us it was a scene also I
couldn't see straight it was not my
fault so you had a nice time huh a good
time a a great time good time all right
I got a question for you fellas I'm
listening I got a fun new little New are
you garbage question oo that came up in
conversation with one of my homies okay
are your great grandparents currently
alive Jesus
Christ
no whoa never even met him I know dude I
have grandparents I never met yeah I
think my dad's dad went at like 42 all
your grandparents are are passed away
right yeah I was just thinking about
that last night yeah my grandfather I
don't know my grandfather passed oh was
that long ago last year grandfather yeah
maybe a year ago um that was your last
one that's pretty good 30 what are you
37 37 yeah that ain't bad he was like
95 buck good jeans in there yeah I
thought he wore khakis but
sure I thought he was a green juice guy
nah he was a steaking eggs when he could
that's good to know you got good jeans I
hope you got a little bit of that down
there at dins off Route n we take every
time we went down we'd see him take him
to dins the diner oh man I could crush a
traditional American breakfast nothing
like a steak at a diner man it's all
right um that's yeah that's a good never
were they alive for me cuz that's
generations of yeah that's crazy yeah
yeah you got you something would have to
you got to have kids real young for that
to happen yeah everyone does yeah the
has them no they everybody has to have
them young for that to happen you don't
have that right are your grandparents
still alive no dead as
hell Jesus Christ it's all [__]
sunshine and rainbows with this guy yeah
my real sentimental yeah my yeah yeah
they're they're all gone all passed huh
yeah my crackhead Uncle really stole the
family's
inheritance you have a crackhead Uncle
oh sure I knew this I might have buddy
of mine from North
Carolina he was my he was my
plug yeah my mom's dad passed away when
she was 12 uh my her mom passed away
when I was a baby my uh my dad's mom was
in a nursing home until I was 14 she
died and my grandfather on my dad's side
died when I was in kindergarten I
answered the phone answered that call he
called you no I'm dying fell little pit
I hate your guts what' I
do stay out of my safe deposit
box yeah man great grandparents that's
wild but there was a great ant floating
around for a little while oh my great an
was alive until I was probably 18 19 no
I think in my 20s my great my m mom
would be your great-grandfather's sister
that would be that line right oh no no
no no a great aunt is your grandmother's
sister your grandmother or grandfather
sister yeah that doesn't count that same
generation yeah yeah my my ain't ain't
that great although I want to say
now I want to say now in my family not
right now but for a minute my one cousin
did have kids early so her mom's her mom
so the babies that's her
grandmother her mom was still alive yeah
they might might have had a little bit
of that but not not directly into me
either way that's trash yeah that ain't
good that's crazy a lot of poor decision
making yeah yeah but hey that's a brood
right there getting it getting it you
know or they're very mature and they
have kids young maybe I don't know maybe
who knows that's trash right there um
yes that is a [__] we might have to
add add that one to the list that's a
doozy I mean that's proper wild yeah
great grandp yeah over
like yeah over 10 that shouldn't happen
no I assume they were in like the Civil
War when I hear great grandparents I
just picture they lived in black and
white yeah you know I no penicillin
everybody's got polio microwaves no
microwaves what we doing yeah
no yeah this guy's in his born in 1930
this guy who the great grandpar the
great grandfather that's my grandfather
was born in like 19 22 yeah or something
like that hm my homie was like I gave
him a Twisted Tea I thought it was going
to kill him oh yeah Jesus Christ shout
out to Twisted te's by the way they
don't get enough credit all these new
companies are coming in they fell off a
little bit no Twisted te has been giving
you the [__] highve no not fell off
quality but popularity I feel like
they've fallen off they've they they've
been given the [__] smoke for a
decade they let off the throttle they
weren't around Wildwood this summer I'll
tell you that I ain't see them any they
give you kid too much of that I tea
gives you kidney stones also gives you
riping heartburn uh I had a cousin was
drinking like 13 Snapples a day and they
got kidney stones and they were like how
much Snapple you drinking they asked
them that it's one of my biggest fears
they're the ones that you pass right you
pee them out Twisted te's been around
for 22 years buddy they you know no
great grandparent no City consumes them
more than Philadelphia Twisted te's
they're like the Rodney danger field of
booze they got no respect yeah know they
popped off late there you go yeah kidney
stones you pee them out yeah or what
there's another Stone gall stone what's
that I don't know your gallbladder sure
do you ever know anybody that passed the
kidney stone oh yeah really I would
freak the [__] out oh I could think it's
good I couldn't handle that at all that
or the gout I'm not sure what do that
when like your toes crystallize or
something yeah the blood C crystallizes
and then pushes it out through the front
of your toes no it doesn't yes that's
what that's what it is it crystallizes
and then it's pushing through the front
of your toes that's why it's so painful
give that a Google I don't think that's
true I thought I was fighting a case of
that for the past coup alien [__] I know
yeah I had a bad toe one time I thought
I thought it was I thought I had the
gout that was it all right let's change
this we're all just going to start
spiraling and calling the
doctor I was I was eating a lot of cream
soups at the time what it does it
something a big chowder moment oh man um
all yeah we let's change subject I'm
freaking out I think I feel like follow
this up does it come out through your
toes uh yes it pushes out through you
can get it in other places though it's
it's in your I thought it was the tip of
your toes but it's in the joint and it
comes out it's like it like pushes out
of the joint but it's not coming through
your body like in Aliens no it's not
like you're not growing stuff I think
it's just swelling and stuff yeah all
right listen we're not doctors we don't
know what we're talking about going to
Toby to tell us what gout
is this is a goddamn Family episode we
got to get to some [__] patreon cues
didn't even think a shower this morning
we're listening to this guy can't even
tell us about grout what okay try to
make a bathroom connection real
quick I want a nday bender give me some
credit talking about the stuff at Home
Depo um guys this is a goddamn Family
episode so uh when you sign up for
patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air it's just the best
way to freaking do it gang yeah uh shout
out get over there on that patreon the
contest is running till the end of
October and we will pick the finalist M
um but all you got to do is sign up and
we'll have them on the show have them on
the show you get your CH you get chance
to get your inter interview by big man
and uh kiino there fun um all right this
one's from Bazooka Joe $10 board member
here never had one read are you garbage
if you got fired by someone wearing a
Hawaiian
shirt that ain't a great job to begin
with man that's Herz Whitey key uh-huh
that's [__] yeah that's tight it's
even worse if it's in like Cleveland or
something that's like uh uh used car
dealer or something Margaritaville
that's on point though I'll give you
that you can fire that's that's
corporate uniform there and for this
reason we're going to have to expel you
from the margarit fille
family they do it like [__] Survivor
turn in your pineapple and get
out that's crazy how big that was that
whole operation Hotel there's a
Margaritaville Hotel in New York oh yeah
to get a get a loc on how many locations
Margaritaville has it's got to be H you
know never been it's like 30 something I
watched a YouTube video of a guy who
went to every location it's awesome
that's fun I would go to that I would
check out a Margaritaville probably do
coconut shrimp all right I thought you
said probably do Coke and some shrimp I
was like all right this guy [__]
parties I'll probably do some Coke and
some shrimp if you need me too some
heroin a little tilapia straight get my
head on straight we we never even we
never shout but rip to James Buffett man
course Legend yeah borderline
devastating for my father the the day it
happened in honor I went over my Bo boy
Ryan's house I get there I open the
fridge bunch of land sharks in the
fridge had a couple cuz that was his
beer had a couple he had land sharks man
I love it
margaritaville's hotels hotels we might
have cuz I for the longest time I we
might have talked about I thought his
cousin was Warren Buffett that's what a
guy used to work with told me and I just
believed it oh yeah we looked it up on
the show that's a proud mom right there
two guys are killing it that's what I
said [__] he's got all that seed
money from [__] Warren um then
doesn't he have like a destination
doesn't he have like Cabo Wabo whatever
the [__] that he probably has like a
some sort of Resort where everybody goes
and hangs out like Hedonism for [__]
for par
heads oh man Dr D down there getting
weird like it [__] look over he's
feeling up a [__] parakeet I can just
see my dad running around with a battery
operated blender and just a Hawaiian
shirt on with no pants just Winnie the
pooing it dong hanging out uh I do need
a chat we do need a check out on
Margaritaville for sure I'd go yeah can
I get a quick menu on Margaritaville can
you pull that up oh absolutely just give
me the apps give me the sharables
there's 23 locations damn that's I
thought there'd be
more you got that's a lot yeah but you
got to think Margaritaville isn't doing
like what an Applebee's does off the
side of a highway somewhere they're
going like metropolitan areas you know
definitely a coconut shrimps on the menu
sure they have some type of tuna um like
uh a lot of deep fried seafood I presume
yeah I bet all right kicking it off we
got the appetizer Trio coming through
with the That's my kind of That's my
kind of thing oh wow well Kippy you this
is built for you bud hand battered
chicken tenders oh the best kind of
battered Caribbean chicken egg rolls
honey I crushed about 15 cheese steak
egg rolls the other night man uh I love
a fusion egg roll spinach artichoke dip
get the [__] out of here with that
nobody [__] with it it never comes out
right always sucks I agree but go ahead
I don't uh Key West chicken quesadilla
this is this is just a TGI Fridays and
they just throw Caribbean in front of I
bet you that's all right though they
throw a couple of [__] bell peppers
and some Chutney in
there [__] dude and I tell you what I'm
all about it a little bit of corn and
some pineapple really or something ah
zesty yeah that's all right you got some
seared tuna yeah of course lava lava
shrimp what's that sh it's I'll tell you
what it's erupting with flavor their
line not mine don't try to put your bomb
on on the great on the late great buff
they no James opened with erupting with
flavor these plump lightly breaded
shrimps are drizzled with our Thai chili
sauce and garnished with toasted sesame
seeds Okay that Thai chili sauce came in
a giant bag and was frozen yeah it does
all right um volcano nachos sure couple
salads no one's eaten those no wag legal
purposes wagu stir fry that ain't real
wagu no shot that's the name of the
cook not sure I get that joke the guy
who's cooking his name is
Wu uh I don't know why K liked it I
don't get it as a name it's a parro head
joke you wouldn't get it yeah it's land
lovers like you don't get our sea
fairing humor sure uh grilled chicken
fish or grilled chicken fish do grilled
fish tacos jerk salmon real rude guy
Cajun shrimp and grits uh yeah fetuccini
Alfredo you got to have that on there
you got to have that on there it was
either going to be fetuccini alfredo or
it was going to be black and chicken
pasta which is always on a menu at a
[__] dirt bag spot that is the Trashy
person's that's the Trashy
chick's favorite meal fetuccini Alfredo
you just call my mom trashy black and
chicken pasta they always go for that
they think they're getting a value or
getting that's like the most expensive
thing cuz when I waited tables at Devon
Seafood anytime some drug dealer came in
with with with with a side chick she
always got the black and chicken pasta
and she thought she was ordering
caviar I hear you yeah now there's
seemed to be over it Jesus Christ Let It
Go chubs it was good now there's one
item on this menu that that you I
guarantee you'll be able to
guess Bang Bang Shrimp at the Jimmy
Buffett Margaritaville roasted toucan
Cheeseburger in Paradise come on come on
well wasn't that its own restaurant
Cheeseburger in Paradise is its own no
that's a goddamn hit I'm thinking of
cheesburger cheeseburger cheeseburger
cheeseburger was in Chicago I thought it
is it's the billy goat but there's no s
it's just ch Burger churger yeah that's
the uh they might have someone might
have ripped that off and made their own
thing but that's that's a SNL sketch
based on a legendary burger spot
underneath Wacker Avenue in Chicago
called the billy goat which is amazing
Acro and Belushi yeah they make terrible
Burgers it's a real good time all right
beer they yell at you um all right let's
see here this one is from Cliff are you
garbage if you skip your cousin's
wedding rehearsal dinner to go to
Chicago live show Fourth sh fourth show
ad and get your ticket sorry if you're
reading this Danny my
man I like it shout out to Chicago baby
for show out and get them Ticky wickies
nothing like stiffing a family wedding
rehearsal dinner should be skippable
rehearsal dinner that's what it was
rehearsal dinner oh rehearsal dinner oh
Dam rehearsal unless unless you're the
best man unless you're the best man
skippable engagement parties skip you're
going to the wedding baby showers
skippable send a gift send a gift send a
gift yeah the rehearsal dinner unless
you're like in the I mean who can't
piece that together the day you get
there you walk down the [__] aisle
and you and you you get in line mhm yeah
get out of here with that although I
always say the rehearsal dinner is
always my favorite part of the wedding I
I love it's low State I do love relaxed
it's skippable it's not a faux po unless
you're the best man the best man or best
broad what their made of H you got to be
there but [__] just an alter on fire
a guy going this is why we rehears
what yeah um all right this one's from
Dixie million dooll homie shout out to
you there you go um have you ever tried
to move something with your mind yeah
all the time I still try to do it I try
to do that I try to do the force and I
always try to do the Spider-Man thing
hoping that the will come out
now over 5,000 on that one just a gout
real bad bunch of crystals come out of
my wrist uh yeah that's something you
always got to try you always got to try
and I always try to guess people can do
it I think that's documented that people
have moved things with their mind what
about um obviously Chris Angel has Mind
Freak what about the movie uh Men Who
Stare at Goats which sucked but that was
based on a true story about a like a
psychic unit in World War II where they
hired a bunch of like psychics and
people that said they were telepathic to
to work for the
government If people could move things
with their mind you don't think that I'm
not saying all the time I'm saying it's
happened one or two times one or two
times one or two times I'm telling you I
think it might I think I I believe that
you think that that's fine I think that
makes sense in The
evolutionary uh progress that eventually
we will be able to communicate
telepathically and we will be able to
move things with our mind maybe with
like Wi-Fi chips or something they
always say the aliens talk to you
telepathically when when when they come
down and and they kidnap people oh the
people the lot the people who lie the
Liars who say they met aliens I mean
you're not like you know you just kind
of threw yourself in with Bigfoot real
quick they just found him they just had
a picture of him on a train he wasn't on
a train was the
conductor he had a briefcase board
tickets PES we're not taking any cash no
there was a couple that was on a train
in like North Dakota or something like
that and this is how stupid you are and
they were film Google it yeah no it's
big foot found that's debunked oh all
right that's from a this guy has a farm
where you go and pay and like it's a
kitschy that guy's a Bigfoot Enthusiast
and then you go on like a trek and it's
like a Disney ride you see that guy at
the end oh I think it's in like I think
it's in like Mexico or something or like
uh yeah no that's fake what do you
got uh on snoops he was like sitting
down on the cff side yeah no was fake ah
God damn it I hate that [__] [__] HX
[__] I will say this it's a very fun
world you live in thank you yeah people
move M stuff with their mind bigo
Bigfoot commuting to his job that truck
just moved that car just moved now you
probably you better [__] knock over a
building at least make you kick over
some beers I was the one who knocked
them
over yeah I try to do that [__] all the
time oh yeah I remember being like 11
years old waking up in my bunk bed
looking at stuff going ah it's still
nothing that's why I always like walking
through a grocery store door that opens
that way cuz when I walk through it I go
like that of course it's opening like
I'm doing it uhhuh I always do that with
like the time people like you know just
like what time is it 4:08 just try try
you know just try to get close and uh
one time with a deck of cards I did it I
was like my's like some kid was like
show me a magic trick I was like I'll
pick a card any card and he's like he
picked one and I was just like four
clubs and I nailed it and he's like
how'd you do that I'm like wait
what well I'm like are you [__]
kidding me you get you get all freaked
out and run home he didn't he didn't
believe me that I just guest tell your
mom she's chasing you around with a Cru
f
[__] get the devil out of my house n
don't play the devil do you ever pick
you ever hit the number not not where
you bet but when I was a little kid my
parent you know they always watch The
Daily number and I one time I guessed it
it was like 563 I nailed it no I thought
that I had
something I thought I was Bigfoot
[__] boom my parents were like what
the [__] yeah it was all right yeah no I
don't I've never uh I don't think I've
ever guessed other than that four clubs
that I'll never forget shout out to AJ
that was his name right freaked the [__]
out of kid it was his name was AJ scorny
eni the scorny enes what a name dude
that sounds like he had poison ivy
constantly that was Joe girton
Jo shout out to Joey G he's on the west
coast doing his thing shout out to
Gogurt that's pretty good he was the kid
that was allergic to it I saw it it
would look like the [__] Toxic
Avenger oh god oh by the way going back
to the Phillies game Tommy Pope saw one
of his boys at the Phillies game and he
was wearing one of the the bad look the
the visor with the fake green hair on it
like and this dude was [__] up he had
like a Hawaiian shirt on goes [__] goes
Tommy who's is that your
lawyer he looked like his name was
slurp that's literally cuz you looked
back it's going on man and just kept
moving shout out to slurp slurping the
boys slurp Law
Firm um all right let's see here um this
one's from Nick this has been I think we
to touched on this a while ago $10
shareholder is a garbage to save a fast
food cup so you can stop and get free
refills whenever you want of screaming
cold Diet Coke I didn't know that that
they did that I think you what who does
that people no no what fast food
companies offer that if I show up to
McDonald's with a cup they'll give me a
free soda Oh you mean just walk in and
do it yourself yeah oh I don't know if
the ones in the city have the do they do
it yourself I guess they don't they do
it for you maybe like the Suburban ones
have the thing like you know at the end
of the which tells you what that they
don't give a [__] about the soda right
like when movie theaters and stuff
started doing that
that well they get the soda for free who
does the companies typ I think that's
the deal you just have to use all the
Coca-Cola cups really yeah Google that
what wait wait they get the cups for
free no I think they buy the cups or and
they get the soda for free or something
like that no they they got to pay for
the syrup yeah they have to pay for the
syrup I I'm asking you to look it up
that's what I always heard they get it
for free as long as as long as they use
the
the product the brand so what do they
what's Coca-Cola getting out of it
advertising yeah all the cups are
Coca-Cola everybody's walking around
with a [__] brochure for Co not at
the movies no no no they they're like
Regal cups or whatever movie theater it
is it says AMC on it well then maybe
they do I know like pizza shops back in
the day this I heard it from somebody
who owned a pizza shop local pizza shop
yeah they would get it for free as long
as they use the the Branded cups I'm
just telling you what I heard no no no
no no I wor no the the syrup was always
coming from uh
like like Manhattan beverage or
something like that they weren't giving
that [__] out for free they were
charging for that [__] I don't know I'm
just telling you what I heard it's the
big soda is the biggest profit because
soda is incredibly cheap for fast food
places the cup cost the restaurant more
than the soda so stealing soda cost them
less than if they give you what maybe
maybe I missed say the cup costs more
than the soda yeah yeah they're buying
the the cups were the the money makers
they're buying the cups for the people
who are set like for McDonald's doesn't
have Coca-Cola cups they say McDonald's
on them so do they say McDonald's and
Coca-Cola they have to they're the
biggest [__] partnership Coca-Cola
has to be on I would assume I don't
think so has to be my point is that they
have a different Coke by the way I know
they have a different ketchup they got
different everything different Sprite
too they put it in the metal containers
that's why good ice too yeah good ice
Mickey these um I don't think [__] just
given they don't nobody cares about soda
is what I'm saying but the movie
theaters that was how you they used to
bang you out when you'd go back and try
to get a refill now they just have the
things out front so anybody could do
that what do you mean you could
literally just bring your own thermos
and fill up those things nobody would
stop
you really Coca-Cola freestyling that's
what they call that's what the machines
called yeah doing tricks don't don't
love them they don't do it in the city
because it would just I I think from
like a an ambian standpoint it would be
chaotic sure
they do it a Chipotle yeah and that gets
[__] chaotic do you ever see that
you're in there eating and the next
thing you know there's like [__]
there's 10 homeless people in there
[__] you know yeah [__] slurping
and taking bass and [__] I Ain got time
for that I'm trying to eat my bowl over
here check at Mr pibs um I wonder how
many Tobasco bottles get stolen out of
Chipotle every day oh it's got to be
thousands oh it's not I mean I remember
one kid I remember would just take one
every day and I'm like what are you
doing with them if you're you know just
like the juice just like the steel I
never got off on it never got off on a
steel um if you're getting me it's not
for stealing a Tobasco bot I'll tell you
that I'm going big yeah better bring
everybody they go through 5.5 million
bottles of Tabasco sauce annually that's
[__] nuts it's a lot most I'd say
half of those are stolen yeah napkins
too sure oh they want you to take them
they do they're branded as well they
have the good so you're in the car and
you open up your glove box you're like
I'm in the move for Chipotle it smells
like Chipotle says Chipotle on it it's
all Mar they got the good plastic forks
too the heavy ones they do yeah they're
all right mhm they're okay except when
the homeless gu in there touching them
all
scurvy yeah that's what they do I'm 10
steps ahead of these guys I [__] get
ever since I saw that guy put meatballs
in his pocket no thanks I apologize for
that all right let's see here this is
from infinite alimony never had one R uh
is it trash to put tequila in my white
called a tiger claw
oo that's all right tequila and The Malt
Liquor is the only thing that would
throw me off man that'll get you uhhuh
that reminds me of the do they sell Malt
Liquor just as a liquor like just as the
just the alcohol I don't think it's that
I think it's what it's made of it makes
it considered a malt liquor it's not
like I don't think you can go buy a
bottle of bottle like like I mean just
just the alcohol part yeah no I think
it's you know m liquor a it's what it's
whatever it's made with I think or the
process mhm makes it like I I forget
Colt 45 was Malt Liquor uh the
difference is uh malt liquor is brewed
with barley and corn yeah corn yeah so
they have to be able to sell the actual
just like a like a you know I don't
think but it's not like a vodka no no it
be the same way you couldn't buy the
alcohol that's in beer on its own it is
the thing okay I got I got it's not like
a vodka or tequila like I got not a
section in the store sure um then yeah I
like it Tiger Claw yeah that's fun I
would just be careful I'm sure that
[__] creeps up on you that reminds me
of every city every dirt bag move when
you go to an all-inclusive and you're
drinking like the [__] daies or the
rum runners or oh shout out to a Rum
Runner like a Rum Runner like a my taii
as you know and uh whatever you order
you order a floater on top so they make
it and then dump a [__] shot of what
and it oh man once I I I was in pun when
I my cousin's wedding when I found out
you could do that good night you're
poting in your pants later talk about
peeing in a pool Daddyo swim up bar I
can get out of a pool for six hours I
had a buddy used to pour vodka in his
beer and he called it fortifying yeah
that's I can't do
that unless it's a Car Bomb I love me a
car bomb an Irish car bomb that is um
all right let's see Andrew first time
long time never had one read is it
garbage or sorry is it pronounced cold
cuts or cold cuts cold cuts I probably
in conversation say cold cuts cold cuts
for sure cold cuts couple cold cuts cold
cuts yeah no it's the correct is cold
cuts yes it's labeled they're cold cuts
of meat but cold cut when you're in the
Acme on a Saturday the Acy yeah and you
got to go I'm going to go get the cold
cuts it was always lunch meat for us
lunch meat yeah we were never cold cold
cuts was like a New York thing I feel or
like not a Phil lunch meat was always
fil what were you lunch meat or cold
cuts
ah and were you ho you were sub a
submarine sandwich Subs yeah [__] it
sounds so dorky lame oh yeah two sub
sandwiches please cuz hogy sounds so
good it does it has a little personality
to be honest with I'm a straight shooter
when it comes to that stuff submarine
and grinders is whack as [__] Grinders
sound sexual if you ask me so does hogi
it sounds like you're talking about
loose women all right I'll give you that
we are also the best name for a speedo
is a hogy Crusher
up without question yeah shut up guy's
on a beach of M with his hogy Crusher I
would go with banana hammock nah hogy
Crusher is more real ban maybe deli
meats deli meats I'm I'm going to go get
the deli meats yeah I just got lunch
meat lunch meat I got I got lunch meat
this there's fresh lunch meat there and
then they run through I got a pound of
cheese turkey Salon okay they ran
through the order on you yeah yeah it
was it was it was always I hated lunch
in Meats I had a my cousin who the [__]
said that that my what lunch in Meats
what it is lunch and meats I believe
that's [__] lame right what is lunch
and meat made out of lunch and meat and
some sausages yeah I I think it I think
the original term is lunch and meat
which I had an aunt say that one time
and I was like don't bring that [__] to
my house a by marriage get out of here
[__] lunch and meats uh I think it was
like an old school like you know old
school Philly way to say people that
would say lunch and meat have I told you
about monkey meat my Aunt Mary Katherine
used to make yes man [__] great so
good I don't know about that so good
chopped up ham and mayo and
relish on a piece of white bread with a
little butter on it that sounds all
right dude let's
go um all right let's see we'll do this
then we got a wrapper up here gang this
is from Zach is a garbage to start my
morning off with a Coke Zero on the
Rocks I do soda in the morning yeah but
only when you're traveling and stuff
that's not that's not a dayto day if
there you if you're wrong the caffeine
thing the coffee thing it doesn't
[__] matter it's the same [__] and I
respect it it's crisper I do if if I got
DCS at the house or if I'm down the
shore I just don't keep DC's in the
house but if I got DC's in the house and
I'm making a [__] I I'm making a
bacon egg and cheese or something at the
crib that's going diet coat for sure I'm
crushing that probably two of them I get
it cuz I'm not a coffee guy but
something about soda every morning seems
wild I don't like sure you're not wrong
you feel it in your teeth after a week
um I he's doing on a rocks like a
goddamn gentleman now I don't I don't
like call I'm weird drinks are
functional to me like I need to bite and
sip I've said this a many times big bite
and sip guy so I need that so I can't
bite and sip with coffee coffee is is is
used after my breakfast to pet me up you
know what I mean get me out of my car
after I was car bloting that's what so
it's like I
can't it's separate it's two you know
church and state you know what and I'll
tell you what uh uh Coca-Cola and eggs
is not a bad combination especially if
you got a you got die C and an omelette
dude all right even if you're doing a
[__] bacon egg and cheese with a
[__] scream and cold DC that's a
sandwich that might as well be a hugi I
do love an omelet that's a smoothie and
a little Diet Coke is oh you go to a
diner you got to get the holy Trio you
got to get the [__] water ice gold
scream and water for the headache you
get a cup of coffee pep up screaming
cold DC for the meal that's what you do
name of the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit die Coke but we got to wrap it up
gang gang this has been a fun one come
out and see the boys on the road get
over on the patreon take advantage of
toies going out of business sale over
there at the this is the last day I
think arug garbage.com yep uh Friday the
20th is the last day for the sale 20%
off everything no code needed uh you
just go over to automatically be be
deducted we got to we got to clear out
the goddamn Warehouse There You Go Gang
we love you we'll see you next week
peace peace